invité le politique ce matin c'est
stéphane le foll bonjour bonjour si
beaucoup d'être avec nous vous êtes le
maire socialiste du mans et on est
ensemble pendant 20 minutes pour une
interview en partenariat avec la presse
quotidienne régionale représenté par
julien lécuyer de la voix du nord
bonjour julien bonjour oriane bonjour
monsieur le foll bonjour et ses fans de
x l'on commence évidemment par les
crises sanitaires puisque le
développement du variante delta inquiète
en france et fait craindre une quatrième
vague dès cet été selon olivier verrey
hier soir justement olivier ferrand les
professionnels de santé ont publié une
déclaration commune en faveur de la
vaccination obligatoire pour les
soignants est ce que vous vous êtes
favorable et des d'avoir ya
effectivement le risque d'une nouvelle
vague et on le voit d'ailleurs
j'écoutais juste avant en espagne ce qui
se passe à partir de là le seul moyen
qu'on a de lutter contre une nouvelle
vague et aidons contre toutes les
contraintes que sa pose et tous les
risques que cela engendre en termes de
décès potentiels
c'est la vaccination et après je crois
une phase où elle a été effectivement
extrêmement importante
on voyait très bien que ça baissé je
pense que la perspective malheureux de
cette nouvelle vague va faire remonter
la vaccination
mais quand je j'entends certains qui
disent je veux pas me faire vacciner
parce que on sait pas les effets
secondaires ma faim les effets
secondaires pour l'instant on les
connaît on les connaît et on les a
mesuré ils sont extrêmement faibles
stimuler nos défenses immunitaires ou se
protéger contre un virus
ça fait partie de l'histoire de la
médecine et de la vaccination est donc
c'est vrai que dans le corps médical qui
est des gens qui doutent de la
vaccination alors que la médecine a fait
des progrès énormes grâce à la
vaccination
et si on n'y a plus de polio s'il n'a
plus de variole
si on a pu toutefois le tétanos avec des
vaccins du luxe contre le tétanos tous
ces vaccins
c'est des progrès énormes et des morts
évitées et donc une espérance de vie
allongée donc du mal à comprendre
comment aujourd'hui au 21ème siècle
j'ai pas de mal elle comprend je vois
très bien d'où ça vient ya une forme de
perte de rapport au progrès et à la
science fondamentale qui est une vraie
question politique et qui se retrouve
dans beaucoup de domaines jusqu'à bien
sûr la question de la vaccination et des
anti vaccins et jusqu'à d'autres
questions sur la fin du monde le donc
oui je suis pour les soignants ont mes
questions subsidiaires les députés les
républicains par exemple pose la
question d'ores et déjà la rentrée de la
vaccination des enseignants de tous et
de l'éducation nationale et ce qu'il
faut garder cette porte ouverte sur une
extension de cette vague d'eau poursuivi
gaillard on a un objectif on sait il
faut 80 % de ceux de nos populations
sont baptisés au moins un minimum à lima
dans cet objectif il faut le garder il
faut se fixer avec en le répétant et en
ayant cette cible après si on n'arrive
pas à l'atteindre et la bascule du côté
du risque à nouveau de circulation du
virus
avec toutes les contraintes qui sont 10
à cette circulation
il faudra se poser un certain nombre de
questions et évidemment poussé et rendre
obligatoire c'est quand même malheureux
la vaccination ça existe déjà il ya des
vaccins qui sont obligatoires mais c'est
mais jusqu'où pour certaines catégories
professionnelles ou pour tout le monde
de la dynamite de vaccination qui va
exister ou pas c'est d'abord ça qu'il
faut regarder n'est pas obligé de tout
de suite dire on va rendre obligatoire
si on voit des choses se déroulent dans
le bon sens et si la cible qui consiste
à avoir le plus rapidement possible 80%
de la population est atteinte
bon messi enfin c'est 80 % ne sont pas
atteints oui on pose la question aux
réquisitions
bien sûr parce que sinon on est sous la
contrainte de la reprise épidémique il
ya d'autres il ya d'autres mesures qui
sont envisagées dans le
et qui ont été discutées avec les
parlementaires l'expansion du pass du
pass sanitaires alors même qu'on
réfléchisse à ce qui est pourtant avait
été exclu au départ à une extension du
pass sanitaires pour les loisirs les
cafés et les restaurants
là aussi c'est quelque chose qui vous
interroge vous dit vous ne fermait pas
la porte
on parle aussi de contraindre un peu
plus sales isolement via même des
sanctions tout ça vous paraît
disproportionnée ou légitime d'un côté
il faut qu'on soit fixé un principe si
l'objectif pour se protéger c'est la
vaccination c'est la vaccination qui
doit être la priorité après si on
commence à intégrer tout un tas de
contraintes
j'allais dire supplémentaires avec des
passes sanitaire obligatoire pour telle
et telle activité
je vais on va se compliquer la vie là il
faut se focaliser à lens ans sur deux
les respects des gestes barrières dans
tous les lieux clos qui peuvent avoir
des conséquences en terme de circulation
sur le fait qu'on impose l'aération
maximum dans tous les lieux évidemment
clos ça c'est un point qui doit être
aussi rappelé et puis qu'on avance
rapidement sur la vaccination
parce qu'après on va rentrer dans des
débats où il va y aura des endroits où
va falloir un pass à lithaire d'autres
pas où il va falloir tout un tas de
règles et de réglementation faut rester
simple sur la vague du cloud et aération
gestes barrières et vaccination sur la
vaccination est ce que les mairies tels
que oman on ne peuvent peuvent aider
alors à la fois en termes de logistique
mais aussi peut-être
on parle beaucoup de d'offrir des des
choses en échange de la vaccination
les mairies les collectivités ont déjà
beaucoup fait un fou quand même le
savoir tous les centres de vaccination
les vaccinodromes aujourd'hui tout ça
s'il n'y avait pas les connectivités et
on assume notre responsabilité qu'on en
est parfaitement dans cette lutte contre
la pandémie donc on vient pas là dessus
c'est aussi pour ce qui est de notre cas
par exemple sur ce qu'on s'est aperçu
que les premiers vaccins pour les plus
de 75 ans beaucoup de personnes âgées de
plus de 75 ans était pas encore vaccinés
qu'on avait déjà ouvert pour les âges
inférieur bon ton qui fois il fallait
rattraper ça donc laissé cesse à
l'échelle de notre pôle métropolitain et
du pays
on s'est tous organisés pour un des
centres de vaccination de proximité et
on a fait en sorte que les personnes de
plus de 75 ans qui n'était pas encore
vaccinée
le soir c'est un principe de redd et
d'applications je les dis de l'objectif
de la vaccination
commençons par ne pas oublier ce qui
devrait être déjà max et qui l'étaient
pas dernière question là dessus puisque
on a compris le point qu'est pour vous
c'est la vaccination il ya un conseil de
défense lundi avec peut-être de
nouvelles mesures de restriction à la
clé est ce que ça veut dire si on
poursuit la logique que les mesures de
restrictions elles doivent être
différentes selon si on est vaccinés ou
paraissent comme près par exemple
envisager de le confiner que les
personnes non vaccinées
vous voyez que si on revient toujours
avec à chaque fois des règles qui se
complique
qu'elle prenne de la circulation de ce
virus tous les lieux qui vont être clos
où il ya beaucoup de brassage ce
comporte des risques diffusion les
clusters on le voit s'est entiché coûté
tout à l'heure ce qui s'est passé en
espagne on sait où ça se passe donc là
il faut faire respecter des gestes
barrières clairement et il fait
respecter de manière suffisamment souple
il y en a qui doivent être respectées
sur l'aération je les dis sur les
distances et des masses dans les lieux
clos
ensuite c'est la réalisation qui va nous
permettre de sortir de ce problème
si on commence à chaque fois que on a un
lieu dans les bars après les commerces
qu'est ce que vous allez faire après lé
théâtre qu'est ce que vous allez faire
et on va compliquer les choses
voilà faut rester simple on va parler
d'un étudiant à parler du climat puisque
le gouvernement donc abandonné toute
idée de ré
un dom climat après le feu après que les
députés et les sénateurs n'ont pas
trouvé d'accord sur un texte comment est
ce que vous regrettez cet abandon de la
part du gouvernement
non je reste surtout tout le processus
qui a commencé avec la convention
citoyenne
j'ai très clair at elle sentait
l'essence dans le sens où a été dit par
le président de la république création
d'une convention citoyenne qui avait
vocation à faire la loi puisque c'était
ça si puisque ce qui était proposé
devait être transcrit sans modification
vous en souvenez sans filtre c'était
l'engagement du président henri c'était
donc l'engagement du président de
proposer sans filtre à la représentation
nationale donc sous-entendu d'abord 150
citoyens tirés au sort
décider d'une loi qui portait sur la
transition énergétique comme quelque
chose d'extrêmement lourds sont qui est
de débats à l'assemblée et au sénat et
avec dedans l'idée d'un référendum sur
le changement de la constitution
c'est bien ça pour finir avec un débat
au sénat qui refuse la modification de
la constitution sur la question de la
garantie de condos a apporté du contre
le réchauffement climatique alors qu'on
le sait il ya des jeunes chats de
l'environnement dans la constitution
et avec cette bagarre politicienne où le
gouvernement renvoie au sénat la
responsabilité de l'échec et où le cedar
envoie au gouvernement la responsabilité
des chefs bravo c'est quoi ces crohn et
ça a fait avancer d'un iota
la question de la lutte contre le
réchauffement climatique non c chronique
d'un échec annoncé ce que c chronique
d'un échec préparer pour être annoncé et
pour pouvoir renvoyer la responsabilité
à l'un ou à l'autre
franchement tout ça ça fait pas avancer
rationnellement politiquement la cause
de la lutte contre le réchauffement
climatique et je trouve que tous à
alimenter un débat je regardais quand je
suis arrivé un débat où on fait
énormément dans un côtes dans un sens
comme dans l'autre
alors qu'au fond la question c'est y
gagnent ça et puis après c'est quels
sont les actes qu'on pose quels sont les
réseaux les réformes que l'on fait pour
justement atteindre les objectifs qui
ont été financés à venir
vraiment atteindre les objectifs la
charte suffit à chacun choisisse dans la
constitution vient sur elle existe dans
la constitution
on a fait un grand débat sur l'idée
qu'il fallait changer la constitution
pendant ce mois est ce qu'on a dépassé
par exemple de changer la constitution
c'est évident est-ce qu'on a parlé par
exemple des changements profonds qui va
falloir opérer dans la finance pour
arriver à faire en sorte que la
croissance de demain ne soit plus une
croissance avec des énergies fossiles
pas du tout alors c'est ça la clé du
débat c'est moi de changer un veau dans
la constitution
franchement j 1 oui alors autres grandes
réformes en suspens ou en suspens au mot
du président et des manuels macro
aurait-il tort de lancer une réforme
paramétrique des retraites en retardant
l'âge légal de départ à 60 4 en cet
automne alors il ya non seulement tort
et deuxièmement il ya un vrai problème
de fond une justice dans la manière dont
tout ça est présenté si je regarde la
baisse des impôts de production plus de
10 milliards d'euros par an décidée par
emmanuel macron présidée par emmanuel
macron je regarde d'ailleurs que xavier
bertrand veut porter sa à 38 à que
michel barnier car il n'y a pas de
problème les milliard pour baisser sa
production a lâché pas où il est rose
qu'est-ce qu'il faut faire en
contrepartie la ce est obligée d'engager
une réforme paramétrique pour récupérer
des milliards qui en fonctionnement sont
évidemment lourd mais qui dans ce
contexte laissent penser qu' on va faire
payer les équilibres budgétaires aux
salariés et aux futurs retraités alors
que ben autre côté on a une forme de
deux de laisser aller dans la dépense
fiscale qui pour moi est complètement
d'abord et à lattes et injuste voilà
donc cette réforme
non il n'a pas à la reposer là avant ça
sera sûrement l'objet d'un débat
présidentiel
deuxièmement la question paramétrique du
report de l'âge de départ
pour moi c'est aussi très injuste
puisque est la vraie question c'est la
durée de cotisation puisque quand vous
rencontrez des gens qui aujourd'hui
partent à 60 ans n'ont commencé à 17 ans
ça a été mon cas il ya une semaine je
voyais quelqu'un qui se frôlent et
j'étais en train de faire un jogging
je discutais il partait à la retraite
jim house avec l'âge 60 ans je rappelle
que le départ à 60 ans à la retraite
c'est un décret signé du président de la
république à l'époque françois hollande
est à chaque fois que je vois quelqu'un
qui part à 60 ans je l'y aideront qu'il
ait fric
44 ans de cotisations dans les travaux
publics méritent pas de partir à 60 ans
sinon pour vont touche pas à l'âge de
départ aux touches pas l'âge de départ
c'est la durée de cotisation qui compte
parce que sinon ouais nan en fait oui
bien sûr mais oui mais oui pourquoi
parce que s'il faut bien comprendre
sinon vous fait financer le système
pas ceux qui travaillent le plus
longtemps et là c'est très injuste
on va parler politique la bataille pour
la présidentielle est lancée notamment à
gauche il ya plusieurs d'élus plusieurs
dizaines d'élus qui ont signé une
tribune en faveur de la candidature dany
d'algos pas vous pourquoi c'est pas la
bonne candidate pour vous c'est le
principe de la méthode qui va pas venir
si on s'intéresse à la présidentielle
c'est que on essaye de porter d'avoir un
débat qu'est ce que c'est que le
socialisme ou l'écologie et la social
démocratie aujourd'hui comment on
prépare ce débat qu'elle est
l'aboutissement ce débat est l'agent
j'étais quand même assez surpris je fais
que ça commence par comme dans le vieux
bon vieux temps des congrès du parti
socialiste par janie des signatures mais
enfin attendez vous avez été même un peu
plus loin dans un tweet que j'ai repéré
maintenant au parti socialiste
vous écrivez on signe pour afficher des
soutiens et on réfléchit après mais
c'est un peu rude quand même visa c'est
très rude parce que je pense que de
temps en temps vous rappeler à tout le
monde que on est à la veille d'une
présidentielle
ils n'ont pas réfléchi avant de signer
mais ils font ce qu'ils veulent je
respecte tout à fait leur signature mais
j'ai quand même le droit de dire c'est
quand même assez impressionnant
qu'aujourd'hui à la veille d'un débat
présidentiel
on commence par signer un texte et vous
avez lu le texte qui avait été signé
mais c'est vraiment la france généreuse
enfin beaucoup d'attention et puis a dit
d'elle go moi je dis m'attendais mais je
me rappelle du parti socialiste alors
peut-être qu'il y avait des travers dans
les débats qui existait avant mais on ne
peut pas préparer une présidentielle
sans qu'il y ait quand même un minimum
de débat et genre j'attends d'ailleurs
puisque c'est ça qui va être proposé
lundi je crois à villeurbanne les
propositions est-ce que vous avez un et
louis
est-ce que vous avez compris que donc on
assiste enfin certains ont signé et puis
après on aura les propositions mais
qu'on comprenne bien c'est la méthode
qui vous pose problème ou c'est la
candidature des mérigots et un wc pour
vous c'est pas la bonne candidats les
agrumes et quel est le projet quel est
le programme
sur quoi on discute je vous ai dit tout
à l'heure par exemple j'entends parler
plein de choses sauf de la finance
quelle est la clé d'un changement de
modèle et de production et de
développement
vous en entendrez parler jamais moi je
vais sortir un livre et je fais bien
montrer que pour changer la donne
c'est va simplement des mesures de
redistribution qui vont compter c'est
pas simplement la sobriété défendu en
particulier par où la décroissance par
delphine batho ou eric piolle qui va
nous permettre d'y arriver c'est un
changement de modèle et de structuration
de notre modèle de développement
ça c'est des débats où est-ce qu'ils
sont posées et ben ils sont pas posées
donc moi je fais faire un livre
je vais présenter des idées et puis
après on pourra aussi dit
sculpter un peu de savoir qu'est ce
qu'on va porter comme avatar
mais messieurs les folles est-ce qu'on
peut pas regretter qu'au parti
socialiste
en effet on se retrouve cet été alors
que tous beaucoup d'écuries ont se sont
déjà mis en marche vers la
présidentielle que là on en soit en
train de discuter en effet de savoir si
on va faire un congrès pour pour
regarder les propositions de chacun et
finalement prenant énormément de sa part
aux autres ans c'est même pire que ça
c'est pas à combler pour regarder les
propositions puisque ce congrès a été
décidée par olivier faur qui porte une
responsabilité très lourde à la fois
stratégiques dans le sens où il a
toujours été sur une logique qui
consiste à dire l'écologie ou socialisme
c'est pareil voire même puisque c'est
l'écologie qui est en dynamique et bien
on peut s'effacer derrière elle mettra
derrière voilà maintenant j'ai compris
qu'il avait changé là il va soutenir
maintenant anne hidalgo
mais ce congrès c'est reconduire olivier
faure et je le dis les textes qui ont
été présentées en novembre de vivaces
sont les ceux qui sont habilités à être
discuté aujourd'hui tenir compte des
régionales de ce qui s'est passé plus
éthique en personne n'en discute ce
parti aujourd'hui n'a plus de vitalité
démocratique
c'est clair et la responsabilité c'est
olivier faure et le corps et du parti
socialiste il porte aujourd'hui de
savoir s'ils ont reconduit ou pas
olivier faur voilà et ben écoute je vais
conduire pour vous ah non je pense que
la vue ce qui se passe vu les enjeux
politiques qui est quand même un
problème majeur qui est posée
stratégiquement la question des
alliances qui a été posée comme un
préalable politique alors qu'on aurait
dû poser d'abord la question politique
je prends d'ailleurs à dessein l'exemple
de la croissance ou de la décroissance
depuis le début et j'ai écrit depuis
longtemps que j'étais pour une
croissance qu'il faut repenser mais sur
qui permet de financer une transition
énergétique et surtout de financer un
modèle social parce que ceux qui prônent
la décroissance finance comment le
modèle social donc pour vous aujourd'hui
ne peut plus être premier secrétaire du
parti
je ne voterai pas pour défier fort il y
avait déjà un débat qui avait que j'ai
perdu y est lui très bien mais au vu de
ce qui s'est passé depuis trois ans vous
dit où sont les débats mais je vous pose
la question
moi j'ai écrit des textes sur l'analyse
du gilet jaune sur la question justement
de la croissance et de la décroissance
j'ai proposé des choses et vous avez
vous avez vous proposer des choses avait
un programme vous allez écrire un livre
pour aller où est ce que vous pourriez
être candidat déjà à la tête du ps
oui ou non non je ne peux pas être
candidat à la tête du ps puis c est ce
que dida à une primaire ou à la
présidence à mai mois je pense que
maintenant ce que je demande c'est qu'on
est une méthode tous les parent est ce
que vous vous auriez envie de pages suis
bien sûr que j'ai envie de porter
guillotine
il faut une primaire mais il faudrait au
moins un débat au sein du ps très ouvert
voyez donc une primaire pour pouvoir
discuter à tout petit peu une première
uniquement au sein du ps une primaire
ouverte à gauche les primaires ouvertes
à gauche les écologistes ont leurs
primaires elle est parti de jean luc
mélenchon il a fait sa primaire cent
cinquante mille rien tout seul tout seul
voilà c'est plus simple que ça il a ses
158 signature il est parti et fait de la
rousselle et candidats aussi et fabien
roussel des copiés sur dix y voit la
hausse est donc il faut y mettre aussi
il faut que le ps organise lui-même un
débat comment ça peut se faire autrement
mais dans une
je ne dis pas un primaire jeu pendant
notre candidat à la présidentielle je
peins primaire veut il faut une méthode
de désignation d'une candidature pas
simplement sur la personne mais sur ce
que l'on propose et je constate et vous
l'avez vous même dit qu'aujourd'hui
qu'est ce qu'il ya sur la table où sont
les débats qu'est ce qu'on propose
comment on voit le monde de demain cinq
ans d'un quinquennat qui arrive quelles
sont les premières grandes mesures
comment on va répartir la question de la
charge de la dette avec financement de
vous demander justin si vous demandez un
système de départage pour but de montrer
qu'elle veut nous
dirt 2 faire exactement la même chose
que font les aurait pu c'est ça non mais
pourquoi vous me ramener je sais c'est
ce que je vous ai dit oui il faut une
méthode pour choisir
d'accord ça on est d'accord oui et ça
doit être un vote je le pense ensuite je
vous ai dit aujourd'hui au parti
socialiste sur la grande question posée
par le projet présidentiel n'y a pas ni
proposition ni de débat et le congrès
qui est organisée ne porte même pas là
dessus ça on a compris donc il faut une
méthode il faut un vote esclave
vous allez être candidat je suis déjà
candidat à porter une ligne et une
orientation après ma la candidature
n'est pas une question de personne pour
ce qui me concerne c'est que je me dis
mais comment on peut aller
monsieur la folle quand on porte ddd
vous avez l'ambition de ce n'est pas
pour après s'effacer en disant je mets
ça au pot commun et puis après vos
débuts
on sent chez vous quand même l'envi élan
et louise ion de faire entendre votre
voix et donc notre question semblait
légitime est de savoir si vote il y
avait vous sentez-vous année légitime à
y participer mais bien sûr que je me
sens légitime l'inversé mais vous poser
la question s'ils votent il y avait là
bas mais vous allez le propose mes
affaires après je sais pas si on va là
où tu roules député revin déjà le le
proposer ce que vous inscrivez dans
cette démarche jeu qu'est ce qu'ils
proposent pierre à leur tour où elle de
la même façon une primaire à gauche mais
ouvertes à gauche
oui mais ça alors ça c'est de ces c'est
ce que je veux dire tout à l'heure au
bruit mais on confronte ou donc il faut
revenir à des choses simples pour vous y
voir un vote au sein de votre
candidature elle entre guillemets n'est
bien sûr et au nom du débat pour pouvoir
justement réussir une prise en ciel je
pense qu'on a intérêt à organiser ce
débat et que de dire il suffit de signer
c'est une erreur ça je veux dire qu'est
ce qui se passe aujourd'hui dans le
débat qui est organisée avec la primaire
des républicains avec la précieuse
écologie bas c'est qu'on parle de ces
primaires et vous vous adaptez qu'il n'y
aura pas de candidat commun à gauche y
compris de candide et je l'aï toujours
l'actrice je les conseille candidat
naturel comme comme à droite
j'appuie il n'y a surtout pas de projets
aujourd'hui qui est sur la table a rien
qui accroche sur quelque chose qui
identifierait ce qu'on peut porter pour
une prise en ciel c c'est ça le constat
que je fais et on a compris merci
beaucoup merci ses fans venus nous voir
ce matin regarde l'accord nord-pas de
calais des inégalités et non la
couverture vaccinale c'est l'un des
problèmes est tout à fait ça les grandes
différences entre les vaccins et
vaccinés merci messieurs
[Musique]